I think we will look back on what's
happening with Trump right now as
completely good I think it'll be the
best thing that could ever happen to
libertarians hi I'm Nicolas be with
Reason TV and we are in Las Vegas
talking to Penn Jillette the great
magician and demystify ER of all things
in American culture and world culture
including weight loss which we'll get to
in a second he's got a new book coming
out presto
how I made more than 100 pounds
magically disappear in other big fat
tales Penn Jillette thanks for talking
to reason go thanks and I when I started
as a professional libertarian 20 years
ago you you and drew Carey were the fat
Fox and I was skinny yeah and now you
guys are skinny and I'm the fat [ __ ]
yeah so thanks a lot for that that's
where it goes you know seasons changed
and so did I you know you you have been
outspoken about Donald Trump and about
Hillary Clinton you were in 2012 you
supported Gary Johnson now you I don't
feel your Bern feel my jealous if that's
right and you and for awhile you talked
about you liked Bernie Sanders you you
found him refreshing not for a while
yeah I was given a very specific job I
was told watch all of the candidates
announcing and critique the videos that
they've put out I was kind of told to do
this just on the videos and the only
person who spoke about policy at all and
the only person with even the slightest
shred of humanity was Bernie Sanders so
I was very clear that I disagreed with
him on everything but at least it was a
human being in a story in Newsweek and
you also kind of talked about this in a
recent issue of Reason you you said as
an atheist you got on your knees and
prayed for a politician who would be
authentic on and God smote you because
Donald Trump is this maybe a little
solipsistic in narcissistic but I
believe what's happening in politics
right now is strictly to punish me
there's no reason I really thought there
could be no one worse than Hillary
Clinton and there is no one worse
and except Donald Trump and I also you
know what we want we got a tremendous
amount of stuff out of Donald Trump that
it's really really good we got absolute
proof from Bernie Sanders and Donald
Trump that citizens united did not
destroy our system the two candidates
with starting out with the least money
did fabulously Jeb Bush was the one who
wins it comes down to Jeb Bush and
Hillary Clinton if citizens united
destroyed or hopefully it didn't and we
have proof of that I mean just absolute
proof I don't know why people even
mention any more we got proof of that
well I think there mention it less and
less right well no I have friends are
just going to get the money out of
politics where you haven't got a chance
and they just repeat that like a mantra
and although Jeb Bush and Bernie Sanders
tell you everything you need to know
about yeah and the other thing is after
all the Bush and Clinton I would have
told you I mean if you talked to me
three years ago maybe you did I would
have told you and maybe I did that I
really wanted someone who and this is a
horribly overused word but I guess I'm
gonna use it someone who was off that
dick run someone who was in some way
honest you know you want to be careful
but honest and once in a while waffled
on issues and once in a while shrugged
and who had some sort of emotional stuff
that it was also sterile I wanted to get
a little bit out of Steely Dan a little
bit of punk rock you know have all that
happened I would have told you that a
thousand times and Trump ticks every one
of those boxes and I didn't add the
important thing oh and with a brand in
his head and not a racist I just thought
that was all that talk about I mean you
were on two seasons of celebrity tourism
with him and from what I understand the
turning point in your relationship with
him is when you discuss there you
describe his hair as being made of
cotton candy made of it looked like I
didn't ever twine it was they would look
exactly like cotton candy mated pissed
how much
that was the turning point the attorney
point actually in those wild times of no
sleep and pretending to be part of
something that's not really happening I
mean we are co-workers on a television
show he's not see if he's gonna hire me
he has no job the places he could hire
me
the casinos that he has that have
showrooms he put into bankruptcy
he no longer owns them so he can't hire
me
plus I have a job so that's all
completely fake right but during the
time it's not Stockholm Syndrome it's
it's it's actors Playhouse yeah you you
get yourself it's an improvisational
five-week improvisational show in which
you've decided that he is the boss and
you are the employee and you do that so
this is like the Stanford Prison
Experiment a little bit a little bit
more like that and then then then like
entertainment so during that time I know
that Donald Trump's line about a lot of
what happens but I also know that I'm
also not correct
because everything gets jumbled together
but there was a time when they asked me
while I was still in the show the
abdominal trouble ran for president if
I'd support him and I said absolutely
not and I believed and this may be the
most damning thing you'll hear me say
about trouble I believed I liked him
more than anyone else was on the show
during that time I said I would not
support him for president and I got a
call instantly instantly from the powers
that be not trumped himself saying no no
no no you you must support him his
present and they said it's going to come
down to you and trace and he's gonna
want to know that you both support him
the president and I said what well I
don't and they said well you really have
to because he's trying to he's looking
at the big picture here and I go we're
on a television show so I was told when
I said I wouldn't support him for
president that I would not win yeah and
if you watch the final show and
don't why would you he says you know
you're being judged on the quality of
your ice cream the quality your final
presentation how much ice cream you sold
he gives a whole list of of the criteria
and then he says pad you did the best
ice cream to the page and he checks them
all off and I want every category and
said oh by the way trace wins now the
Walgreens people were very upset by this
because they wanted to sell my ice cream
and do all of them and NBC was very
upset by this they're both so upset in a
matter of fact that they gave money to
my charity kind of under the table so I
actually ended up making more for my
charity than traced it because of kind
of guilt money going in they were very
upset
I was not because the rules of this show
are that he decides who wins and there's
no other little you know as a
libertarian we care very much about the
rules we really do and if you and I are
playing a game and I've decided when I
go in that whatever you say goes and
then you say something I'm not allowed
to say that's unfair there there cannot
be no no unfair I also like to say our
Celebrity Apprentice that I am a
terrible terrible chess player I'm
horrible but I can sit here with you and
tell you what the rules to chess are I
can tell you with the rules to text them
Texas Hold'em or I can I can lay those
out to you I did two full professional
runs of Celebrity Apprentice and did
very well and did as well as you can do
and still be a failure and yet I can't
tell you what any rules are there is not
a game being is that what you I mean
what a trump presidency which ultimately
is unlikely but is what not one of the
things that worries you about it it's
like we would be in America where there
are no clear rules although he gets to
decide them not going for a joke
and just trying as hard as I can to tell
the truth I think
he doesn't really have strong
convictions and sense of right and wrong
he's not really really smart he's not
stupid you know he's not a dumb guy but
he's not smart like presidents are smart
we big jokes
everybody makes jokes except me about
george w bush not being smart he's smart
he just is Obama's smarter probably sure
Obama smarter than Clinton probably you
know almost certainly but they're
they're up here you know and if we're
talking about it you know you're
wherever you are but you're not smarter
than Obama you know none of us are even
the smart guys you know aren't there and
Trump isn't one of those people he's not
someone that when you're having a
conversation with him I probably listen
to him talk for I don't want to
exaggerate but probably eight or nine
hours of a monologue of Trump and I
can't think of one thing he said that I
went oh yeah huh now try to think of
someone in your life that could talk for
eight hours and an albeit is on TV and
it's it's it's you know to be chopped up
and put on there give you that he's not
trying to be particularly profound oh it
seemed like he was that's not true for
Obama I don't think Obama could talk to
you 15 minutes on any subject without
you saying either I didn't know that or
I'd never thought of that undoubtedly
both of those and more than once and
isn't that the minimum you need from a
president now these two things cancel
because if if Trump were to become
president which i think is so unlikely
it's insane
but if he were the powers of the world
crush him he doesn't get anything done I
mean Obama a good man I think a
wonderful man who I think we disagree
with but a wonderful man
was completely boxed in and able to do
very very little Clinton who really
understands the game is I think from but
this is a cynical way to think I don't
like to think but thinking cynically
Clinton is probably more dangerous than
a trump presidency because she'll
actually get stuff done what worries you
the most about Hillary Clinton like
what's she gonna get done that really
freakish I just think bigger bigger
government I mean Trump should not be
someone we're scared of if the
presidency had not gotten so big you
know it might come down to I don't mean
to get this is a very high school II
thing to say but I think all the same
true you know in the 1940s we decided
for maybe good reason I mean I don't
have a better idea that because we
wanted to have mutually assured
destruction one person had to be able to
launch nuclear weapons we decided that
now that that goes way beyond
dictatorship that's a horrible decision
I mean I haven't got a better one but
it's a horrible decision so we now have
one person who can actually do huge
destruction in the world I want to be
overly dramatic and say blow up the
whole world but they could they could do
certainly do a damage though and I
really believe that Hillary Clinton as
as much of a war monger as she is and
she will certainly be the killing US
president we've had in a long time don't
think she'd hit that button you know now
Cruz bragged about how he'd hit the
button and Trump I don't think really
bragged he mentioned it but I can just
see him if someone questioned is the
thorah time yeah in the right way I can
see him just saying I mean can you and I
create a crazy - can I can I ask is the
rise of Trump because as you were talk
about in Sanders in his own way these
were independents who kind of took over
these old parties that are dying is it
kind of great though that he is probably
going to destroy
the Republican Party her force it to
change what it stands for yes yes yeah I
mean probably if you and I were having
this discussion in ten years
I think we will look back on what Trump
what's happening with Trump right now is
completely good I think it'll be the
best thing that could ever happen to
libertarians I mean I it's beyond all
ready it's beyond good and Clinton is
also helping I mean now I know you've
said that you know if your vote is gonna
matter or you think it is you're gonna
vote for Hillary you'll put a Hillary
sticker on your car but your heart is
with Gary Johnson or with the
libertarians and I also have what I
wanted out of my presidential candidates
I will also give to myself the ability
to change my mind right I will be
supporting Gary Johnson right away I
think one of the problems I talked to a
guy in in LA I'm kind you know pitching
a show or something but you know a guy
who has a lot of money and who you would
who you would typecast as a liberal like
this and he said and maybe I'm missing a
joke ride wouldn't see the irony but I
don't think I was I think I usually know
a joke and it bites you in the ass he
said oh I'm supporting Trump because I
want to watch it burn yeah I think
there's a lot of that I mean anybody in
the intelligentsia who's supporting
Trump is supporting him to watch it burn
I don't think any of them believe he
will fix anything but you know I believe
that if I hadn't sat in a room with
Trump for a long time I might have a
more accurate assessment of this I might
be confused by the fact that not that
guy no not nobody weighed oh no no no
and I also feel a little bit you know my
friends talk to me and I and they start
talking about Trump and I say
however bad you think he is he's worse I
mean you don't have the intelligence of
the imagination now I say this all
within within the box this is a story
that is so important to me you know I'm
Al Franken I work with on Saturday live
and we weren't friends friends but I was
over his house a couple times you know I
I probably knew him personally a little
better than I know you
which is you know we're acquaintances
I've never never talked for hours and
when Al Franken was running for the
Senate he wrote me an email and said
would you support me and just do a few
little things for me to be senator and I
wrote back to him and said you know al I
like to work with you you're a good guy
but I disagree with a lot I'm a
libertarian I can't in good conscience
support you I really don't want you to
win as much as I like you I disagree you
know and he wrote back and said well
it's good that you're a libertarian
because your ideas will never be tested
but thanks a lot and hope you pass cross
paths again and since then I bumped into
him hello how are you
when Donald Trump was running I I was
asked I'd be the first person that asked
me is lawrence O'Donnell
well asked me you were around Trump what
do you think was that and I said you
know I kind of liked him I thought it
was good in the show I think he has a
lot of skill sets for the show I think
he's a good person you know it's some
level I mean it's not my favorite person
to hang out but I do not want him to be
president I do not agree with him on
anything
I believe he's wrong on everything
almost precisely what I sent it said to
Al Franken and his reaction was start
tweeting out my magic show was awful yes
terrible magic show and it made me think
you know and actually there's this video
that is interesting I think I'm not
interested in now but I think I might be
in a few years I'm on Opie and Jimmy
show on Sirius when the tweet from
Donald Trump comes in so I have two
cameras on me and a mic in front of me
at the moment I read a presidential
candidate attacking me there and my
reaction is just yeah that's a reaction
I can see
happening but we're supposed to be
better than if you're gonna be our
spokesman yeah you've got to be better
than you are personally you've got to be
better and Trump the very pettiness and
the very honesty that I respect him for
so much if you're going to be President
we can't have that
you know we're sure we are absolutely
positive that George Washington was a
miserable prick but when he spoke he
spoke for all of us with a great
conscience and I'm not sure you want a
president who's taking shots and a carny
performer I think you're much more of a
I mean I don't mean a dam with faint
praise but you're much more of a
historian than I am
do you have an example in American
history of a serious political candidate
attacking a trivial personality do you
have like Lincoln going four score and
seven years ago I saw this magician who
really saw it or maybe maybe he's slag
John Wilkes Booth yeah well yeah I mean
that's it's not and then you respond it
very nicely oh yeah you tweeted back
like it well I'm sorry you missed her
you couldn't make it to the show yeah
well so are you
are you worried about the future and I
yeah you know when I think about you and
this has to be it could be 30 years ago
you weren't politically incorrect I
think what it was stolen Comedy Central
the panel was talking about how like oh
we're running out of aluminum and this
is a big problem and and then you said
you know what it's not a problem because
when we run out of aluminum we ran out
of ten and then we made cans out of
aluminum and we'll make them out of
something else or we won't need cans and
you're like a super optimist in this
sense right are you worried about the
future in a way I mean you have two kids
yep you don't do you think they're gonna
end up in a world if it's the Hillary or
if it's Trump you know or other people
like is this a time to be worried about
the future I mean I would really like
our president to go to another branch of
government before killing people
overseas that was a big mistake and kind
of letting that slide more and more and
more and then letting it really slide
under george w bush and then really
slide under obama
he's going to bite us in the ass as
heavily with Hillary Clinton as it
possibly could you get that we're now at
that those two levels you jump up back
and forth on one person killed overseas
in my name is a tragedy you've got to
say that okay that having been said and
you can't shrug it off but that having
been said I don't think that things will
get horribly worse with even one of the
present I mean I want to be four because
that's what you do sitting around with a
coffee with your friends you want to get
a apocalyptical and I can't believe how
terrible this is and these may be I mean
these may be demonstrative ly the two
worst candidates we've had in history I
mean it's in terms of what the American
people think of them has there ever been
it doesn't seem like you should be able
to run for president with over fifty
percent disapproval you know and I also
and people have argued me on this and
they could be right but the other thing
is so odd is that anyone who knows Obama
is an Obama supporter if you meet Obama
even if you disagree with them you go
WOW it's a good guy I think anybody who
meets Bill Clinton goes that's a great
guy I loved hanging out with them
I certainly true for Jimmy Carter
certainly true for Ford you know
certainly true for LBJ certainly true
for John F Kennedy we've had in our
history one president who people who
knew him personally didn't like him and
that was Nixon and now we have I know
people who give a metric shit-ton of
money to Hillary Clinton they give her
money they are supporting her and these
are guys that give enough money that
they could hang out with her there they
give enough money they could hang out
with Bill Clinton and did and liked them
and they god I can't stand to be around
it Trump there's nobody who knows so
well in this family and so on who's
supporting
you know are they demystifying politics
in a way and like one of the themes i i
see and i think i probably heard this
from you but you know one of the themes
in your work and Penn & Teller's work as
well as your own self is you'd like to
demystify you know the world and why
things happen the way they do or how
they might happen differently do you
think people like Trump Trump and
Hillary I mean they are so despised that
they force us to look at the mechanics
of power and how people rise to power
that they might demystify some of the
things that we've taken for granted well
yeah okay well we'll just let the
president kill whoever they want we
don't have to do anything I mean maybe
they will force us to it I don't know I
mean that would be a that'd be nice
I just wish I also you know what are the
interesting things about gary johnson is
that and it when it hits you it's so
remarkable is he doesn't preach fear
mm-hmm you can't find gary johnson
saying you know if you don't vote for me
it's the end of the world you know if
you don't vote for me things will be
okay I think I could make them a little
better which is kind of a politics
should be right I mean when you got
slogans like you know make America great
again I mean that is such an unpleasant
slogan on so many levels I don't even
know what Hillary's is but working
together for me well good let's talk a
little bit about this kind of
demystification process that you're
doing your work the earlier I mean this
year you've released director's cut
which is a you know a crowdfunded movie
about a crowdfunded movie you're the
movie that you did before that the
documentary that you helped reduce Tim's
Vermeer which is about you know how did
for me or do this stuff and come we kind
of reverse engineer to paint a Vermeer
and it's demystifying you know how he
did in a Vermeer is particularly
interesting since you probably used the
camera obscura and all of that kind of
stuff no but okay yeah okay so what we
could we'll get into that and a
different conversation and then you're
the third season of the shove the show
fool us which is about magic like how do
you do it and it's also great because
you guys love to be fooled look but it's
all about you know kind of showing okay
this is how it's done
where does that impulse come from in you
it comes you know I I tell the story
over and over again of you know seeing
Kreskin and thinking his mental powers
were real and why didn't see that as
science and how much that upset me as a
twelve-year-old for whatever age I was
and but you go through a period when
you're 16 17 18 when truth really
obsesses everybody and then I think
you're supposed to kind of sort of grow
out of it and I I didn't I didn't I'm
really it really remains of complete
interest to me because you know you get
more sophisticated I know that that
truth is not this magic Diamond bullet
you can automatically have but just
because it's elusive does not mean it's
unimportant you know and so I don't care
about that and I there's some of it
that's just on a nothing to immorality
it's just all your detective stories are
the search for some sort of truth and
there's really very few stronger
positive emotions you can have than the
AHA that feeling of discovery of
understanding something and what
detective stories give you as a false
aha they make you think you figured
something out but they you haven't
remembers you I guess it's not a
detective story but your novel sock is
also kind of like or an attempt to get
yeah yeah and it's a really nice form
it's a it's the short story for you know
it's a really nice form that I like and
I do also believe that we all are
working together to try to ascertain
what this world is that we live in you
know and working together and I get
there
be very bothered I I'm not bothered at
all by people being wrong because I
think on absolutely everything I'm wrong
you know
I'm fine people being wrong I am I have
such a naive point of view to almost not
believing it that people can have
information and represent the opposite
of that I just I just find that so
appalling and in a certain way
fascinating and so it's not so much
demystification as it is just well how
can we how can we figure this out a
little better how do we get to that and
then when someone comes along that's
actually giving and I'm one of these
people you know I remember this story
that amazing Randi had and flim-flam
when somebody and I think they took over
that the TM people the Maharishi took
over that town I was and I are yes yeah
and they announced that the crime rates
had gone down this enormous amount and
Randy was sitting there looking like I I
think this is the kind of thing you guys
do to going well they say crime rates
gone down there might be an angle on
this it might be that so many of these
people have moved in and it's thrown off
the demographic it might be that they're
doing a self policing and he spent a few
days on this and then he called the
police chief of the town and the police
she said no crime has a gun and that's
yeah that's the that's the trick I
always fall into the trap I fall into is
I always think you know a local
entertainer here just announced crazily
he was making like 70 million dollars a
year and we were sitting around going
from and then finally someone just said
he's lying that's how he's stupid you
try to say he's cutting the absolute
gross what he could be making if every
seat was sold
what do you know he's not the crime base
just didn't go down and that kind of
stuff I always think there's a finesse
or there's some sort of oh I was a
little bit there's a clever wording
there I'm always thinking there's
weasels that are doing these little
sliding things and sometimes it's just
out not lying so what I'm not good at is
the out not lying stuff you know stuff
like Vermeer where there's there's
really no lie made it's just we've gone
down the garden path I'm fascinated by
but somebody who just says oh no I
should so well you know there's a real
generosity of spirit in that of like
trying to you know ascertain truth and
share it publicly and also showing the
steps I mean this is you know I've seen
your act multiple times and you know one
of the things that is great is when you
show how things are done and it's more
complicated than that but in presto you
I mean this is like Ben Franklin's
autobiography how I made my way in the
world but it's how I made you know a
third of myself okay right um talk a
little bit about that like what what you
know what motivated you to do that
or motivated you I mean I'm sure you had
started weight loss for a long time and
but this time you've you saw it all the
way through yeah
you know I'd always been there's so much
to up to say about this I have I believe
the strongest disclaimer ever at the
beginning of this book only a few you
know what I essentially say is if you
take medical advice from a Vegas
magician you're an asset actually you I
don't know if this is where you say if
you take medical advice from a juggler
right right you're an [ __ ] I I've
never been asked to write a book before
the books that I've written when they
cover atheism and libertarianism and so
on are things that I really wanted to
write when I started dropping weight
really really fast which was just a side
effect what I really did was started
getting healthy really really fast
people my friends plus people on the
streets
said tell me how you did this somebody
do this and my answer would always be I
don't know i'm not a scientist you know
only 600 people have been through this
we haven't get any control groups it's
you know we know know that half what I'm
doing is [ __ ] and accomplishing
nothing but we don't know which half we
don't know where this is I mean you're
on the nutrit Aryan type yeah pretty
much
can you just explain that I do pretty
much no animal products I don't like to
use the word vegan because vegan has a
lot of political but no animal products
and no refined grains you notice there's
no mention of no GMO there's no mention
of organic although all that stuff
overlaps not to me no animal products no
refined grains and then extremely low
salt sugar and oil there's all this
stuff that'll say olive oil is really
good for you and stuff all that stuff
gets thrown out you get plenty of oil
salt and sugar if you want none of it
you'll get plenty that's what I eat and
then every couple of weeks I go out with
friends or something and eat what I used
to eat which is remarkable because I had
to promise myself that cuz I thought I
was giving up something but now there's
no craving there's no desire I mean I
can sit around people eating
cheeseburgers and pizza and it it means
nothing because you change your
microbiome maybe but that's what a lot
of people think and you also change your
taste you know your taste it I think a
lot of comparisons to music you know I
mean you you bang out that three-chord
rock-and-roll and you absolutely love it
and then at some point in your life you
listen to a little bit maybe you get
there by Zappa but however you get there
you get two miles and you get to
Stravinsky and you get to Sun Raw and
all of a sudden you realize well that
that you know that four on the floor but
three chords is really really nice and a
guy screaming about [ __ ] is really
nice
but there's all this other stuff out
there and I've been eating those same
flavors salt sugar and fat I've been
eating for you know 60 years and all of
a sudden I realized wow there's actually
a taste to corn besides salt and butter
who's actually all this and it's so easy
when you're unhealthy to lie to yourself
everybody helps you you know not to
there I'm not blaming anybody else but
we have it's very easy to find an excuse
to eat that cheeseburger that night
and I also don't believe anything anyone
says in the hospital right around when
they come or on New Year's Eve I don't
believe anything anyone that's amount of
time when we're all lying all the time
you everybody so I didn't make some sort
of big profit I was in the hospital high
blood pressure but I made no big
declaration so I'm gonna do and to me
and I don't know you'll find that this
book there's never been I don't believe
a weight-loss book with more
first-person singular in it there's
almost no second person I don't tell
other people what to do for moral and
artistic reasons on this because I don't
know but if your question is what do you
think you did I answered that completely
thoroughly but for me and this is so
simple now is so hard then I've never
been proud of anything easy and when you
think about it very few people are
people brag about climbing Everest they
don't brag about climbing up a hill the
small incline a nice grassy you know
grassy walk and every diet I tried you
know what I call the New York Times
grown-up diets or you can eat just the
way you're eating just a little bit of
portion control have you a little
careful on this and why not be vegan
till 6:00 and then only eat meat at
night and why not do this it won't
change your life at all and all of a
sudden you know like a diamond bullet I
went I've never enjoyed anything that
didn't change but like for the hall and
isn't that what life is is changing it
you know I didn't learn to play upright
bass bebop because someone said to me
you know you can learn this without
doing anything just take what you
normally do in the day and kind of slide
a bass string under it no you want to
play to your fingers bleed and just you
can look at them and see them bleed in
if you're not getting better
it's the effort that's the fun of it and
in magic you know teller and I we don't
need any new material we have we have
outrun the clock we have five and a half
hours of material and how many years to
live couple decades if we're lucky to be
working with you we're not gonna use up
that material the audiences in Vegas
rotate we do new tricks simply because
we like to do new tricks and we choose
the new tricks based on how hard they
are and believe me we don't tick off the
easy ones you know so it was hard is
that impulse to remake yourself or to
challenge yourself is that a is that
just a personality temperament you're
born with or is it an ideological
commitment almost or you know is it is
it an act of will or is it just who you
are
III you know you can you can disguise
the nature nurture question any way you
want and I can't answer it but uh I mean
he's not busy being born his busy dyin
let me because and this is my final
topic
I did not realize this about you because
I had read poorly in your life story but
Bob Dylan who you just quoted is one of
your heroes why is Bob Dylan one of your
heroes and how devastated will you be
when he and he will eventually when he
passes like Bowie or Prince or whatever
I've got to tell you no I was I was good
friends with Lo and he losing Lou was
really really hard the one that snuck up
on me and you know you say Bob Dylan
will die and I do know that I didn't
know George Carlin would I just didn't
know it none of us were ready for that
you know I think we were more ready for
Lou Reed but I mean George was just okay
well he'll be going I'll have to deal
with his death sometime but it won't be
for a long time I've been a fan of a lot
of people and you I you know I hate it
that we have this culture that tries to
turn everybody into fans and then at the
same time ridicules that we use the
phrase fanboy and people will come up
and say I feel like such an [ __ ]
I'm a big fan of yours and indigo don't
don't do that
you know I am proudly a hardcore fan at
the time I met Lou Reed I was president
that'll read fan club and he told me I
had to stop that if we're gonna be
friends
which is true you can't do that what did
you like about Lou Reed and then we'll
get to do it I love the blending of
levels neither Living Dead George
Romero's first movie his description of
it not the ads for it nothing else was
I'm not gonna get this word-for-word so
forgive me but it'll be close he said
that'll be dead is what happens to
America when a truly radical political
form takes over pow
that's everything making a monster movie
with intellectual content is the best
for me now The Velvet Underground or
this dirt dumb banging Punk with an
Aaron Copland scholar playing viola over
it and with you know Delmore Schwartz
short story type lyrics all kind of
mixed together that Warhol thing of is
this really stupid or is this really
smart that mixing I am a complete and
utter sucker for so Lou Reed having this
intellectual college guy at the same
time this motorcycle boots guy you know
that the best example of this when
unfortunately the band doesn't play it
out but the best example is a stupid
rock band named Steppenwolf you know I
wish they'd done a little more I mean
yes you're gonna do much more than born
to be a wild monster monsters monster
which for those of you who hopefully
will never hear it is an attack on
America by a Canadian band but yes but
so Lou Reed really had that yo but Dylan
you know I look back on the music I
listen to and you can't trust your
musical tastes at all three years plus
or minus your first [ __ ] that
information is not valid so I
tell me when you first had sex then tell
me the music you like from three years
before three years after and you're not
allowed to talk about that yeah you're
not allowed to because maybe that song
was playing during it's nailed in it's a
different thing happening but I look
back on the music from when you're
really forming so many of the bands get
worse and I I shouldn't say this but I'm
going to The Beatles are still a very
good band but they're not as good as I
thought they were in 68 or 69 a really
good stuff I mean
Hey Jude a revolution there's wonderful
stuff there I'm not in any way putting
them down but they're coming down a
little bit not a shitty band but a
little bit still probably the best band
maybe but a little bit down but Dylan
you go back to blonde on blonde and it's
better now but that's not the surprising
thing if you and I were sitting talking
after blood of the tracks came out you
know plug the trash comes out we're
sitting there talking and then you say
to me and you know something
this guy'll do a better record than this
in 2005 how high are you Nick the fact
that you can go see Paul McCartney and
he does a wonderful wonderful wonderful
show it's full of hits
he hits every note the band is hot the
band is tight it's exactly the show you
have expected him to do
if you guessed from 1970 what he'd be
doing oh these fireworks on Live and Let
Die sure they're of course Dylan I defy
you to say what is going to be doing six
months from now he is just driven by
pure art you know his son said to me and
I you have to be very careful to not
break confidences but I don't think I am
here his son said to me there is no
doubt that if my dad had never made it
if he was sitting on the side of the
sidewalk with his guitar and a hat out
in front of him he would be doing
precisely the same songs his whole
career would be exactly the same
now there's certainly hyperbole in that
but it's kind of sort of true and I've
also found out and I didn't know this I
don't know how I didn't know this but
Christopher Hitchens Solomon Rushdie
said enough name dropping in one
sentence Salman Rushdie told me that
Christopher Hitchens used to play this
game where you could name any line from
any Dylan song any time in his career
including the Christian period and
Hitchens would give you the next line
Wow and I went really how come I didn't
know that he's a lot that I thought up
that Salman Rushdie is this whole world
is Dylan you know and I really think if
if we have anybody who's Shakespeare in
our time it's Dylan and he just speaks
to me more and more and he once said in
an interview that the the purpose of art
was to inspire and when you see a Dylan
show you would think he's so good you
know if you go see a jazz cap who's so
good playing bass you can leave that
show going why do we even pick up a bass
again but for some reason and I'm not
the only one that feels this at the end
of the Dylan show art just seems so good
I want to go write a play I'll write a
novel I'll stay up all night write a
song and you don't care that it's not
it's not as good the other thing I love
about Dylan is he is a freak not a
cheerleader when you go see Springsteen
it's all this inclusive stuff you know
don't we all love girls and cars and
don't we all have an economic downturn
and don't we all want justice and we're
all here and yeah oh and let's go and
it's this feeling of camaraderie the
whole show everybody's Bruce Springsteen
and you might want to make comparisons
between Springsteen and Dylan and I
think it'd be completely wrong because
even if they both have gravelly voices
and both come from the same traditions
he's a cheerleader and that's good
nothing wrong with that but Dylan just
stands there
and says I am speaking for me maybe some
of this is true for you too I don't know
but I'm digging so deep all of his
mining you know is going towards his
heart and deeper into his brain he makes
no attempt that I can tell to say oh
yeah this is gonna kill him
this is what they'll like and that's
where universality has to live you can't
be universal if you're trying to please
other people
you can only be universal if you have so
clearly who you are and Dylan has no
idea who he is
but he's still searching and he's
sharing that process with us and you
know people tell me you know you're such
a Dylan nut what album should I listen
to and I always tell them stay with the
21st century you don't even need to go
before them who else and I would throw
in Chronicles is probably the most I
think it's the best fully realized beat
prose it's better than Kerouac you know
it's and that is like a whole other
genre for him
that is awesome thank you as I consider
myself a Dylan nut and you have given me
a new appreciation you know that about
Asians I did not I did not and I wish I
had people that I know and read about
who are really literary they will always
come up with Shakespeare Burns Dylan
yeah you know and it actually and this
is I mean this shows what a bad
education I had actually the past few
months I've been really going through
the Shakespeare stuff going wait a
minute you know if he's I guess he's the
Dylan of his time I guess he's the Dylan
for all time I guess he really is the
best
I should be no more about you well we
will leave it there and we will also
leave people not knowing about presto
your latest book how I made more than
100 pounds magically disappear and other
big fat tail and you'll also find
libertarian stuff in there all right
well you know I think the way that you
were talking about Dylan and that search
but
for truth but also self recreation and
and not even invention as much as it's a
search I find that very consistent with
a kind of libertarian ethos so thank you
for that feel my Johnson well we will
leave it there the man is Penn Jillette
the latest book is presto thanks so much
for such a pleasure